so this is the 2014 World Series ring
every single full-time member of our
staff got the World Series ring how cool
is that
I think we know were part of something
special Series win for the San Francisco
Giants for the third time in the last
five years every April when the crowds
start coming back in when it's the start
of the season there's this renewed sense
of wow
something I love about working for the
Giants is that we have people from all
different backgrounds and fields within
the team I'm not sure that anyone would
have said that there's a Job Description
around someone who's interested in
sports and real estate but that's what I
wanted to do and and I you know figured
out a way to pull it together to get
there and I think everyone really has
that in them
[Music]
[Applause]
the most interesting thing to me is
really seeing all of it come together
and seeing how things like finance and
engineering and law have this really
incredible intersection in urban
development so the northernmost part of
the project site that is right across
from the ballpark is going to be a new
five acre regional park with waterfront
access and recreation opportunities and
retail along the parks edge and then
there'll be twelve new buildings with
offices and homes and restaurants sixty
percent of the seats in the ballpark
have a view of what's happening on La
day today so imagine in the future when
that view instead of cars and parking
lot is of parks and trees and beautiful
new homes and buildings I think what
excites me the most around this sort of
work is that it's going to be part of
the city for hopefully generations to
come
[Music]
one of the things I remember learning at
the GSB was that we actually can
experiment from time to time and I have
to remind myself of that so sometimes
when I'm stuck in a situation or I don't
know quite how to respond I'll actively
think to myself I'm just gonna
experiment I'm gonna try something that
I don't think I would normally do
because maybe that'll get me past this
and sure enough it usually works
[Applause]
not in charge
the biggest thing that I would share is
that if you think there's a place for
you out in the world that doesn't exist
yet and you want to go create it you
absolutely can that doesn't have to be
sports that doesn't have to be baseball
that doesn't have to be the niche
intersection of real estate and baseball
but whatever it is for you go find that
and the more you love it the better
you're going to be
[Applause]